[Music]
that's what I'm talking
about hey Chef wonderful here and I want
to talk about dumplings yes I love
dumplings and I think they are just the
most amazing food it bring so many
cultures together it's such a healthy
snack or you can be decadent if you want
you can go everywhere with a dumpling
that's why I love come on Brooklyn
dumpling shop you know if you're going
to do dumplings do them right that's the
whole key you care about the ingredients
you care how they're prepared you care
about the flavor and the
experience let me tell you about
dumplings you know it's all about the
texture I mean this is a food that's
popular all around the world but there's
nothing like a Brooklyn
dumping World legendary that's why I
love them are you ready for this and by
the way does this go well with wine no
kidding particularly you know something
like a Moscato that really brings out
the flavor so let's give this a
shot
that's what I'm talking about you can't
believe how good this is Korean
pork oh my goodness and the thing about
Brooklyn dumping is you can go anywhere
you can go mac and cheese if you want
you can go vegan you can go gluten-free
you can do whatever you like but oh I
mean bear with me one more
that is so good I mean you've got to
experience this you've got to try it
next time you see a bag of these pick
them up try them just say Chef wonderful
sent you and I know what I'm talking
about when it comes to
dumplings
oh look I'm sorry I got to have one more
bite
I mean come on come
on cabet sveno dumpling
[Music]
M you know I'm I'm going to cry I'm
going to cry you combine it with a
fantastic Splash fine wine Shameless
promotion of course but what are we
talking about
here I mean the great thing about a
dumping it is portion
control trying to strength you know trim
you want to lose some weight eat three
don't eat six it's a beautiful way to
decide just what you want I ship them to
you Frozen just heat and eat and you
decide which ones you want you can't go
wrong and all over the country now
Brooklyn jumping shops so when you feel
like one tap it in your phone and bingo
we make it for you fresh and delicios so
Maxim moso are you kidding now dumplings
there's all kinds of ways to make them
and eat them because there's so many
different flavors and that's what we
specialize in you know I've been waiting
to get into dumplings for a long time
and I've finally done it Brooklyn
dumpling shops everywhere all the time
247 what a fantastic healthy snack or if
you want to get decadent you can go
there too whatever you like sometimes I
want to be
healthy sometimes not so much you know
what I'm saying I want to indulge and I
can do it all with
dumplings
fantastic Brooklyn dumpling shop do not
forget that name you want dumplings you
want them from Brooklyn dumpling because
they're just delicious ious so many
different flavors so many ways to go all
kinds of upside here why because we know
what you like and we've been blending
and making these for a long
time delicioso
maximos all right Chef wonderful back
with you at dumplings here's what you
got to understand about this food
delicacy treasured all around the world
it's Multicultural everybody loves a
dumpling but it's not just the dumpling
experience it's the
sauce and the number one Rockstar Hit
Parade sauce is the peanut sauce my
peanut sauce is off the charts why pH
you know what PH is that's the acidity
to get it just right is nearly
impossible but I know what I'm doing cuz
I'm Chef wonderful so let's say you're
going to take a chicken dumpling just
ordinary chicken dumpling classic
semi-healthy pretty tasty millions of
them served all around the world you
want to make it special you take a
little of the chef wonderful Brooklyn
dumpling shop peanut sauce a little dip
that's all you want just on the edge
there
wuah save her just Savor it's like a
fine wine you can
just oh my goodness my mouth is watering
because it just you know it's going to
be
spectacular that's it that's the
combination that's the explosion of
flavor you kidding a little splash of
the beautiful fine
o
ready I mean stop the madness I mean I
can't stop you know this peanut
sauce I you know you have to experience
it it's a color it's a color AR orgasm
that's what this is if you're going to
eat food you got to try
this oh I mean it's just
insane just
[Music]
insane get your fingers into
it I
mean it's so delicious you can't stop
and that's the key blending the flavors
together blending the flavors M Cabernet
s
it you there's so much going on here the
peanut sauce pH is just perfect with the
crunch of The Dumpling absolutely
beautiful experience the texture in your
mouth and then the follow through that's
the whole thing about this experience
you got to savor it there's so much
going on
stop stop stop stop stop
stop I mean that's just
insane if you haven't
tried Chef
wonderful Brooklyn dumplings you're
missing a whole element of your life I'm
not kidding now you want to go healthy
got it got vegan you want gluten-free
got it got gluten-free you want to go de
it mac and cheese yeah baby I'm talking
mac and cheese one of our most popular I
like the chicken I like the beef I like
them all what's not to like and then the
sauce you've got to try this by the way
this sauce is so perfect the
Skippy the king of peanut butter yeah
we've co-branded with them that's how
big the sauce is you think Skippy would
put it on any sauce no way it's got to
be the perfect Chef wonderful perfect pH
perfect and by the
way I blend the sauce to get it just
right see that it's just perfect where
do you get Brooklyn dumplings at your
favorite grocer that's right we prepare
them we freeze them for you at their
peak of freshness you just heat and eat
you choose what you like don't forget
the sauces my goodness the peanut sauce
is to die
for
m m the texture
M that's the whole thing about dumplings
it is the most exciting interesting
texture flavor rich food you can ever
eat total abortion control have one have
two have three get what you like you
want vegan you got it gluten-free you
got it you want decadent yes you got
that too we got it all and by the way
you're going to find this product
everywhere you shop now would you like
to get into business with me in
Dumplings call me about a franchise
exploding all over the nation why people
love dumplings that's why it's a brand
new food group in the sense people are
discovering it but it's been around for
centuries and it's so
delicioso every every culture loves a
dumpling they have different names but
they're basically dumplings yeah you
remember pot stickers forget that we're
talking about dumplings the purest Chef
wonderful
nose all right guys next stop for you
try a dumpling not any dumpling Brooklyn
dumpling shop you got it see you soon